дорогі друзі Сьогодні можливо для декого
найбільше найважливіше найкрутіше свято
в році свято захисників і захисників
України це справжнє наше українське таке
поєднує в собі Чотири свята свята
Покрова Святої Богородиці свято УПА
свято українського козацтва і наше вже
чисто українське свято захисників
України і нарешті цього року вже всі
зрозуміли що нічого важливіше армії
немає
всі зрозуміли що лише збройні сили є ті
хто дарують Україні майбутнє і ті хто
рятують Україну врятують український
народ і представляє собою найкращу
частину українського суспільства
український народ мільйони українців
підтримують
забезпечують і сьогодні з повним правом
відноситься до захисників
благодійники які забезпечують збройні
сили Волонтери які збирають на це гроші
лікарі які лікують наших військових
рятівники які витягають із-під
розвалів після Росії
наших
жінки які плетуть маскіровочні сітки і
ніхто крім них більше не робить і ті хто
робить життя нашого воїна трохи тепліше
Бо нічого
авторитетніше захисників не існує наше
збройні сили захищають не тільки Україна
а Європи і весь світ наші збройні сили
не дають нікому мати жодних сумнів тому
що вони перевозять І сьогодні ми
приїхали на якраз бо Саме тут найкраще
зустрічати день захисників Сьогодні ми
знаходимося дуже близько від фронту
Сьогодні ми знаходимося разом з нашими
десантниками і для наших десантників для
того щоб вони могли лягати
артилерію перевозити мої комплект мати
тут у нас і маніпулятори все мати дуже з
високою ступеню проходності вантажівки А
разом до цього ще 100 буржує як бо
взимку Вночі вже -3 А разом з ними а у
теле і квадрики які ви чуєте і сьогодні
вже наша Десантура навчилася збивати
нашими
ворожі дрони і я хочу сказати що
спальники карімати фліски
зимові брюки зимову форму і все це те що
складається наша звичайна буденна робота
забезпечення збройних сил але сьогодні у
нас свято я всіх вас
лісники хоче привітати всім Наших
українських святом які було запроваджено
8 років тому я пишаюся що під тим указом
стає мій підпис і я пишаюся тим що це
наше свято було одразу сприйнята всіма
без виключенням
Слава Україні і слава збройним силам
України
вже переможем обов'язково